FAMILY.
JOHN.
>> John: SUCH A SAD ENDING TO
ALL OF THIS, SANDRA.
BORDER AGENTS CONFIRM LAST WEEK
13 MIGRANTS DIED TRYING TO CROSS
THE RIO GRANDE INTO THE UNITED
STATES, HEAVY RAINS ARE NOW
WARNING PEOPLE TO NOT CROSS THE
BOARD.
TOM HOMAN JOINS US NOW.
IT ILLUSTRATES THE RISK THEY
ENGAGE IN EVERY TIME THEY CROSS
THE BORDER AND YET THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT SEEM TO
BE DOING A LOT TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION OTHER THAN CUSTOMS AND
BORDER PROTECTION WARNING
AGAINST PEOPLE CROSSING IN THE
HIGH HEAT AND EXTREME WEATHER.
>> AND THIS IS THE ONLY NETWORK
TALKING ABOUT IT.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE CLOSING IN ON
1300 MIGRANT DEATHS SINCE JOE
BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT, 1300,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT.
I WAS IN BROOKS COUNTY A FEW
WEEKS AGO AND DID A RIDE ALONG
WITH A SHERIFF DOWN THERE, AND
IN, EXCUSE ME, IN FOUR HOURS WE
FOUND TWO DEAD BODIES.
I ASKED HIM, I SAID HOW OFTEN?
AND HE SAID TOM, WE ARE HAPPY WE
FIND ONE IN FIVE.
THEY HAVE EITHER BEEN EATEN BY
ANIMALS OR ARE NEVER FOUND IN
THE BRUSH.
MANY IN THE RIVER WE'LL NEVER
FIND.
1300 WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT.
AND THAT'S NOT INCLUDING LIKE
THE TRAGEDY IN SAN ANTONIO, 53
DIED IN THE TRACTOR-TRAILER.
THE NUMBERS ARE HISTORIC HIGH
AND THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
TALK ABOUT IT.
AND THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW
HUMANE THE POLICIES ARE, IT'S
NOT HUMANE WHEN YOU HAVE OVER
1300 DYING ON U.S. SOIL BECAUSE
YOU HAVE AN OPEN BORDER, CAUSES
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE TO
PUT THEMSELVES IN THE HANDS OF
CRIMINAL CARTELS AND THE
JOURNEY.
>> FIRST YOU ADMIT THERE IS A
PROBLEM AND THE WHITE HOUSE
SEEMS TO DENY THERE IS A PROBLEM
WITH PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
LET'S GO BACK TO LAST MONDAY AND
PETER DOOCY'S EXCHANGE.
>> SOMEBODY WALKS INTO TEXAS OR
ARIZONA UNVACCINATED, THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO STAY?
WHY?
>> BUT THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
>> I KNOW THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU
WANT TO HAPPEN BUT THAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE SOMEBODY WALKS
OVER AND, THAT'S NOT -- THAT'S
NOT HOW --
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE WALKING
IN A DAY, SOME OF THEM TURN
THEMSELVES OVER, SOME ARE
CAUGHT, TENS OF THOUSANDS A WEEK
ARE NOT.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
>> John: A LOT OF PEOPLE WALKING
ACROSS ARE ALSO CARRYING DRUGS
WITH THEM, AND A BIG DRUG BUST
IN A CAR IN NOGALES, ARIZONA,
47,000 RAINBOW FENTANYL PILLS
DESIGNED TO ATTRACT CHILDREN AND
187,000 BLUE FENTANYL PILLS.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
HOW MUCH ARE THEY CATCHING
VERSUS HOW MUCH IS GETTING IN?
>> THEY ARE CATCHING JUST A
FRACTION.
AND MOST OF WHAT THEY ARE
CATCHING IS AT A PORT OF ENTRY,
WHERE EVERY CAR IS STOPPED.
THE OFFICERS MAKE A
DETERMINATION IF THEY SEARCH AND
NOT FIND IT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING BETWEEN THE
PORTS OF ENTRY, BECAUSE OF WHAT
SHE'S IGNORING, SHE SAYS THEY
DON'T WALK ACROSS THE BORDER.
1.7 MILLION DID LAST YEAR, AND
THIS YEAR, MARK MY WORD, WE'LL
BE AT 2.4, ALMOST 2.5, 700,000
MORE THAN LAST YEAR WAS A
RECORD.
AND THAT MANY PEOPLE COME
ACROSS, UP TO 70% THE AGENTS ARE
PROCESSING.
70% OF THE BORDER IS WIDE OPEN
AND THAT'S WHEN THEY MOVE THE
FENTANYL ACROSS AND RECORD
NUMBER OF FENTAN